I'm on board with this god damnit oh can  I not even do that I mean that just  leaves my mouth right feel like I'm  gonna hurt myself  okay get it get it just go for it go for  it kid  touchdown that coffee is in the cup  let's get some creamer boom Oh cold  just wanted to let you know Kevin what's  a good day a bad day  it was terrible day why because the  White House is casting doubt on North  Korea's claim that it detonated an  h-bomb so the only way to get to the  bottom of this is to send basketball  ambassador Dennis Rodman over there but  if in fact there was a nuclear bomb  detonated over there he may become  radiated and turn into a giant  man-eating war humanity's don't  you